madam vice president they
trained thousands of people for careers
and
in a bunch of different classifications
under the culinary union but
you know some of the most in demand
positions for example our guest room
attendants and
food servers and and um
a lot of the hospitality workers
obviously have been the most impacted
during this copic
uh pandemic and while we are working to
crush the virus and thank you for the
support with the american rescue plan
um it's also about helping people
acquire the skills
and the retraining and with innovation
there's some impact
that some of geo's members have faced
and so
it's also about making sure that as we
reopen those
properties and bring those tourists back
that everybody's ready to get back to
work with the skills
they need and that's the lifeblood of
this economy here
so are you finding that you're that
you're retraining some of your members
for different skills yes
what kind of skills people who go back
to work
so they want to improve their career you
know and different type of jobs
they coming over here or sunday one
after training again because they didn't
have to work
you know from last march you know we
have
one year almost that's why we extend the
unemployment rate
because you know six months and that's
when you're considered
long term right yeah
so we've extended it now to september
300 yeah march 18 they're gonna have
one year
[Music]
thank you for your skill
that's a nice smell that's great
but it has lavender
freshly ground disposal i can smell it i
can smell it
so tell me about the training program
for this for this for baristas
so yes pepper's fountain worker and
barista and it's really important
because
front workers do so many things on the
script it's a classification that's
evergreen
so they learn so many different things
things like
uh crew tls
and they're also staffed in very
different areas and casinos
everywhere from stores coffee shops to
so it's there's a lot that here they
have to receive
uh
when you're dealing with coffee drinks
there's a lot of menus and it's rather
intricate actually
apparently right
right and a large percentage of the
workforce
are women and people of color yes and
yes we know that they have been the most
impacted uh
yeah and so making sure that we're
working to
support them not just in getting back to
work but
with the child tax credit with the
housing with the child care
the health care benefits through cobra
those are all essential benefits
that people need in order to get back to
work safely
which the union's been working really
hard it's not just
that we don't want the properties open
but they can't open until there's demand
until they're safe for everyone to do so
so what have you been saying in terms of
your members
and how they are getting through these
days what are they doing to survive
well is it being very difficult for them
yeah really
because they make it seem so painful uh
you know we have
70 percent of the membership they are
still out in about two years
and we have 126
members 70 million families because away
from the condemning
and right now what we're doing for them
you know
we're working with the culinary
financial academy
for healthy food products and working to
with the
governing you know with your
unemployment yeah with utilities
and trying to keeping everybody together
to because we have something back to
work
because you created a fund also didn't
you
yeah yeah career workers yes
we we are really really
uh close to them right now within this
pandemic yeah
and we passed the first legislation to
understand with
right yeah so i saw that and i saw an
article about one of your members and
she was hoping she would
be called back to work this week i think
yeah i think she's going to have
because the governor started uh having
all the hospitality and restaurant
workers they're on the priority list now
for vaccinations so
over the weekend there were thousands of
people at the cashman center
and at the convention center getting
vaccinated so they can as
they are called back uh to work be safe
for themselves and their family most
importantly but also for the public
as those properties return the governor
also increased
capacity at the venues up to 50 but
that's only because we've been crushing
the virus and yeah
you know the numbers have continued to
decline which is a great sign
but we've got to continue to make sure
every community knows how important it
is to get vaccinated and
continue to practice cnc guidelines so
that we get through this together
we were i was with the governor earlier
at unlv at the vaccination
i mean that room was passed people have
been vaccinated they were waiting there
15 minutes before they could leave
everyone was wearing a mask
and um and it the governor took the jj
shot
i took them out there and i was saying
the president took the the
pfizer so just reminding everyone
whatever vaccine you are offered take
when it is your turn we have to spread
the word
make sure everybody does that yeah i got
mine i got my tools
whatever line they will send me i will
be okay that's exactly right
that's exactly right right now would
make an
effort you know for um because you know
the african-american community and the
latino community we're really behind and
the island pacific we really designed
with the old
vaccination program and it's because
it's a lot of
myths about my vaccine and the union
here we have people thank you
the union we have this program to give
information about
the facts about the vaccine but you're
right one in five latinos nationally
is been infected with the virus more
than eight aftermath
and then you know the numbers in terms
of mortality rates
thank you so much thank you please enjoy
thank you guys so very much thank you
for being such an
artist and for all of the training and
good luck
with your barista career this is
wonderful thank you
thank you very much thank you so much
thank you you did a great job oh yes